[Musique]
c'est un homme qui sort de son silence
ange milhas beaux jours bonjour vous
êtes le président de maddie via cette
société coopérative agricole vieille d'à
peine sept ans dans le secteur de la
viande est l'objectif c'était la
commercialisation de la production pour
ses adhérentes de dates en juillet à
février 2007
alfred marie jeanne président d'as
etienne qu'il lance un pavé dans la mare
tout est opaque selon lui dans la
gestion de la coopérative notamment dans
la gestion des fonds européens et en
septembre 2010 est le journal
interentreprises qui fait état de
plaintes déposées par deux coopératives
à bruxelles et à paris sur toujours sur
la question de ces fonds européens
il y à des enquêtes en cours on en est
où dans ce dossier eh bien monsieur
jeunes gens monsieur marie-jeanne je
pense qu'il a été mal informé et on le
sollicite on invite à chaque fois de
venir voir ce qui se passait je suis sur
ce qu'est ce que les producteurs et les
salariés de manifestions transferts vont
directement par rapport à ces visions
idéologiques je dirais du président du
président la cité alors on est ouvert à
ce qu'ils visitent et qui viennent et ne
pas prendre les propos des gens qui sont
des fondeurs à l'époque
à l'époque lorsque vous avez sollicité
vous étiez agacé vous sembliez vouloir
porter plainte quand toutes ces
personnes qui jettent l'opprobre comme
ça sur ma divialle notamment des
entreprises en phase avec le président
de la ctmb quand même mais contre quoi
ce journal ah oui ça a été fait et une
fois tient encore au et puisque un
certain moment il faut réagir
pourquoi selon vous pourquoi selon vous
il y aurait une sorte de complot contre
vous vous déranger vous l'aimez bien sûr
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des producteurs
de matériel on entre et de changer un
certain dub et à établir on en train de
révolutionner son modèle économique
agricole la preuve ce ça donne ça donne
des résultats l'homme
aujourd'hui c'est une forme de jalousie
je dirais et de memis parce
qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui avaient la main
mise sous ce système
ils n'ont plus et les producteurs qui
gère l'eau production de 2 c'est ce qui
dérange selon vous avez bien sûr mais
bien sûr puisque sa charge lors des
tables et je vous dis donc avrillé coûte
roche des pieds-noirs capoter
aujourd'hui c'est ça voudrait dire que
il ya que certaines personnes d'ici qui
ne connaissent pas le travail qu'on a
fait les collègues des autres
départements sont admiratifs je parle de
la doyenne de la voie d'eau soit négatif
de ce qu'on a fait qu'on a réalisés et
ils sont dans la première semaine de
décembre ils sont ici pour pendant
quelques jours pour visiter et pour
décortiquer la mise en place de la
nouvelle organisation rhône a mis en
place depuis sept ans et l'autre la
veille le mondial le modèle économique
on a mis en place a permis à la
martinique de se hisser au deuxième rang
des régions de la planète en termes
d'organisation de la production
d'élevage mais n empêche que les deux
places qui ont été déposés font désordre
bruxelles la demande aux instances
françaises à paris des comptes et paris
n'est pas très content de ce qui se
passe à tel point qu'il ya des il ya des
rencontres et par exemple il y a deux
jours trois jours avec la haute autorité
de la concurrence nous demandent de riz
de changer les règles parce qu'on va le
rappeler 1 2 coopérative porte plainte
parce qu'elles estiment être lésés elles
ont été écartées de du système et donc
ne peuvent pas recevoir 10 euros pour
monsieur le temps c'est pas de
coopérative
ces deux associations on retrouve un ou
deux producteurs de dents qui n'ont pas
qu'ils sont pas organisés suffisamment
pour être considéré comme une
coopérative qui porte le plein ils ont
le droit mais aujourd'hui la bouder soit
des points c'est quoi eh bien on a des
ambitions sont en cours non non ça a été
ça a été réglé l'un concernant la haute
autorité et les amants alors aujourd'hui
les gens pro tu peux penser que le
règlement qu'est ce que c'est
dans l'interprofession raison de
fonctionner comme elles fonctionnent on
nous sollicite à continuer à travailler
et on ne demande pas de changer les
règles pas du tout pas du tout d'accord
du tout mais n'empêche que tout cela ça
fait quand même désordre dans le dossier
de terre du journal interentreprises de
septembre dernier on a l'impression que
tout ce qui concerne la production
agricole notamment dans le secteur de la
viande a baissé
la règle d'or semble être l'opacité
atouts de passe passe pas du tout
monsieur aujourd'hui m'a dit que c'est
un ensemble de producteurs qui se sont
mis ensemble avec avec des statuts avec
un règlement on est on est contrôlé
régulièrement par les services de l'état
par l'euro par la daf
il n'ya pas ne pas citer au bout de vie
les producteurs sont contents de leur
coopérative et je tiens à le remercier
de leur du travail qu'ils font tous les
jours et chaque matin jusque pendant
toute l'année
je tiens à remercier aussi l'ensemble
des salariés qui font un super travail
pas dans l'opacité
le travail qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est
d'amener une production saine de bonne
qualité une façon aux clients et aux
consommateurs kif qui ont choisi de
faire ce geste patriotique de choix de
faire la préférence de la vienne local
alimenté par pourquoi fait-on état d'une
surproduction notamment dans le secteur
du poulet une surproduction organisé et
10 tonnes de viande jeter à la poubelle
au sol et déjà je peux pas avoir de
production de suproduction m'entraîner
que c'est pas possible
l'ensemble de la de la production
organisé devienne mon unique ne
représentent que 3 mille tonnes dans ces
trois mille tonnes ma d'hiver
représentent 78% 3000 tonnes de viande
produite si aux 25000 tonnes importées à
quel moment on peut parler de sio
production concernant la vienne jeter
des tonnes de vienne jeter s'étoffe
c'est un mensonge
si on a les photos qui ont circulé non
il ya des déchets y aller il ya il ya
des gens qui disent qu'ils témoignent
voir des camions entiers venir
aujourd'hui je voudrais aujourd'hui si
on a les carcasses peut-être des déchets
monde
non mais elle est déjà aujourd'hui entre
avec de la viande alors expliquez nous
as pikine et je vous explique que vous
voulez aujourd'hui on reçoit un produit
brut poulet avec tous ces plumes et où
tout il faut il faut le travailler il
s'en produit du déchet il ya aussi aussi
des produits
pour plusieurs raisons qui deviennent
impropres à la consommation
moi on s'était dit dans un mas divialle
de mettre sur le marché des produits qui
respectent plus le cahier des charges de
qualité qu'on a qu'on a mis dans leur
fonctionnement est aussi jeudi vers les
obligations en vigueur concernant la
viande fraîche
alors moi je vous dis qu'on a on doit on
doit avoir une certaine honnêteté un
respect pour les martiniquais qui ont
fait le choix de cette production est de
2 mètres sur le marché des produits qui
correspond à cette qualité et
aujourd'hui personne ne nous empêcherait
de détruire et c'est ce qui ce qui est
préconisé de diriger cette proportion
mais quelle proportion aujourd'hui les
portions de produits tous confondus qui
sont détruites représente moins de 1% de
ceux condition qu'on produit ce qui est
une performance à par rapport à ce qui
se fait au niveau national qui aux
alentours de 7%
on n'a rien à se reprocher ceux qui
veulent faire des photos ils peuvent
continuer à faire des photos on va
continuer à travailler donc dans le
respect de 2 des commandes et des règles
en juillet lorsque je préparais cette
émission j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'interroger vous vous en doutez bien
plusieurs acteurs du secteur qui disent
vous savez à travers le pays les fonds
européens et il faut bien comprendre une
chose c'est qu'il ya beaucoup d'argent
déversés par l'europe dans cette filière
agricole pour parler des poulets les est
arrivé ou pas des subventions les
pousser à sautiller kani et l'agent les
les plumes qu'a commencé poussé à les
pousser en uni ont ni l'agent les coupes
et couleurs unis l'agent ça fait joli
gâteau que certains auraient je parle
bien de vos détracteurs que certains
voudraient garder pour une même
peut-être parce que jusqu'à en un mot
c'est la mafia
comment c'est à dire aujourd'hui
l'évolution la situation demain divialle
fait que ces gros connu et on a
confectionné mon adn qui nous qui vient
de commencer notre production pour être
concurrentiels sur le marché
j'avoue des quelques chiffres et à 126
millions je crois duo qui entre en
termes de subventions pour l'agriculture
martinez il ya que du secteur confondu
toute cette eau profonde
y a que 10 millions d'euros qui sont
qui sont dirigés vers la production
animale 10 millions d'euros sur les 126
et combien va-t-il marie vialle reçoit
aux alentours de 5 millions d'euros
quand ils voient présente 78 % de la
production organisé ça voudrait dire que
c'est même pas à l'équivalent de ce
qu'il voit prison alors moi j'ai envie
diot la majorité de cette somme là s'est
passé s'est passé c'est par les éleveurs
aussi les gones culture bien entendu et
on représente 50% de c est de là qu on
m'a dit viens en termes de production
d'organisation représente plus de 78 %
de la pollution
aujourd'hui on a pas de honte à ça ces
aides européennes sont versés après
vérification de travail fait et d'une
réalisation justement on pointe du doigt
on semble pointer du doigt notamment le
rôle de la mif qui l'association
martiniquaise interprofessionnel de la
viande qui elle permet d'orienter les
dossiers pour savoir qui va tout ce qui
va recevoir les fonds européens
pas du tout c'est ses parts est pas là
mais qui détermine l'éligibilité des des
demandeurs c'est l'état c'est le projet
l'odeadom l'ami venait qu'une instance
qu'il était également prêté du doigt
également dans dans le circuit dans le
circuit parlée par les plaignants
c'est à dire l'odeadom le lien dans les
services de l'état ça c'est aujourd'hui
l'odeadom et de services qui
accompagnent toute forme de
développement de mise en cours mais des
moyens pour pouvoir augmenter la
production dans nos dom est-ce que les
autres la production des oeufs ça fait
partie de vos de votre champ d'action
non pas du tout on ne fait pas de porte
pas chance que vous ne voulez pas ou
bien ils ne sont aujourd'hui éligibles
par exemple dans dans les compétences de
maddie vial non il est tout à fait libre
aujourd'hui peut-être dans notre quête
peut- on va peut-être se pencher
l'actuel mais aujourd'hui il était
important de consolider et de de ce
qu'on fait déjà une dernière question en
milhas parce que le temps nous est
imparti il le temps qui nous est imparti
est presque terminée
est ce que tous ces bruits autour de
marie vialle vont vite retourner parce
que selon vous toutes ces accusations
sont fausses et infondées
mais bien sûr bien sûr et aujourd'hui on
a fait le nécessaire au niveau de la
justice
on continue on a fait notre travail
monsieur violon et j'en veux dire chaque
fois que le groupe demande unique a
essayé de sortir de l'eau et bien la
politique c'est la politique du french
with et samedi sur l'égoïsme du french
with etc il faut il faut les massacrer
et on a on a une mauvaise habitude de
soutirer la médiocrité nous on est des
producteurs professionnels qui se lève
tous les matins à faire un produit donne
un produit de qualité à nos
consommateurs quand je tiens à remercier
et sollicite à ce qu'il continue à
chercher un espace nautique merci en
juillet président de m'a dit viens
d'avoir été ce matin dans 104 bonne
journée merci
[Musique]